let's jump into this story for the post
millennial
rich women of the view want illegal
immigrants in New York resettled
elsewhere uh what no no no no no no no
this is a sanctuary City okay but
frankly you know I think we need to find
and we've dealt with this before I I
lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant an
immigrant in Miami in the 80s you'll
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift yeah 125 000 Cubans came in a
matter of six months it puts tremendous
stress on on on a city on a community on
the social services they need to be
resettled elsewhere
this is a massive country and it's only
going to get worse with global warming
and climates
okay I'm gonna pause right there Joy
Behar and um I don't know the other
Lay's name no you're a sanctuary City
you voted for it New York is a sanctuary
City we should keep sending more in fact
I I hereby call on all border states to
send as many people as possible to New
York City they absolutely should well
there are a lot of places especially
like New York and these people will vote
for stuff because they're so isolated
from it like they're not there they're
not on the borderline oh yeah you know
Texas New Mexico Arizona they have to
see it every day because that is where
the flood is coming yeah and that
they're they're over there two and a
half thousand miles away like oh this is
fine oh we should be a sanctuary Stadium
like that's really nice you don't have
to deal with it you're disgusting and
that's why they that's why they can can
have those opinions because it's not
real to them it's an abstraction that
they don't have to worry about that
doesn't touch them now that that's why
Eric Adams is all oh we're always going
to be a sanctuary City because the
number of actual illegal immigrants that
they were getting because of their
geographic location was totally
manageable
as soon as you change the situation and
start launching people in a New York
City all that of that bravado about
worst Sanctuary cities that stuff's out
the window because in reality these
policies that they swear up and down
that they want to have don't effing work
period just don't work like you have re
you have bumped into reality and when
your ideology bumps into reality friggin
all right reality wins every freaking
time
you are on the border you live on the
border my house is probably as a crow
flies like maybe two and a half three
hours from the Mexican border two and a
half three hours do you spend this
you're running for the house uh
representatives for 23rd District uh
yeah TX uh CD 23. what's the Border
situation like in your district oh it's
it's and it's atrocious like it's it's
so uh the Texas district 23 I I'd liken
it to like a dual-sided wrench right
it's like the western side of San
Antonio uh to the Eastern side of El
Paso so it has more border Frontage in
that District than any District in the
country
and it's it's just insane you see a lot
of these border towns and whatnot are
dealing with this problem every day and
you have the the the class of Rich
liberal intellectuals that can postulate
about these things but they don't have
to see it they're isolated from it so
they they
get to have these you know Fantastical
opinions about oh this is what the way
we should be treating them and oh I
can't believe you do that but they're
not seeing the fact that and now a
statistically
uh important percentage of the U.S
population in the last five years the
increase in the U.S population has come
from illegal immigrants crossing the
southern border you know what the number
is I I heard the the term five million
or the the figure 5 million the other
day in the last uh I think since Biden
took office I'm not sure if that's
correct I imagine so many of them are
undocumented yeah five million that are
document that are away people are aware
of so like is this is no real way to
know is this yeah what's the sentiment
of the people in the 23rd District like
oh from especially not only just from
common sense but from all the polling
that we're doing is like the the
immigration issue is the number one
issue in the district these people are
fed up with it and they're fed up with
the way that politicians are handling it
how would you protect the district what
would you do differently so I I like a
lot of like chip Roy stuff some of the
stuff he's put up which like Tony has
actively worked against Tony Gonzalez
the incumbent Republican I'm running
against uh because he's
it's it's it's basically just a trying
to shut down the Border entirely
which is what the guy is trying to do
what chip Roy yeah chip Roy is actually
I would say a really really good
Republican he's uh he runs uh the
district at uh Bernie Texas right down
the road for me uh that that District uh
he's he's got some really really good so
like he's a very firm border guy shut it
down like what would that first of all
what does it even look like is it just
flat people could just walk across a
sidewalk or is it a river it depends
there's there's well there's there's a
river there that that's a lot of the the
viral footage that's gone you know
around the internet lately where they
had the the buoys with the the quote
unquote saw blades oh yeah oh yeah we
gotta remove those now yeah I think uh
there there's been a lot of moves by the
Biden Administration to actually
actively remove uh border barricades and
things were those put up by locals uh
they were put up by the state I believe
I believe and it's like they were
floating buoys with literal saw blades
between the buoys
yeah yeah I looked at it it's not like a
like a malicious looking saw blade it
looks like a piece of you know sheet
metal that has a jagged edge it was
cutting people and killing them or
something
it's obstructing U.S waterways that's
why they have to remove it okay so
that's it when you say shutting down
what would a shutting down of the Border
look like because I feel like it's not
like what does that mean exactly well
there's a lot of border patrol folks
especially that are tasked with managing
that section of the border that aren't
given the equipment and anything that
they they need so that they're purposely
being uh I guess suppressed in that way
that's a lot of frustration so uh is
that excuse me headline for the New York
daily news two bodies found stuck in Rio
Grande floating barrier along U.S Mexico
border according to Mexican officials
yeah yeah if you didn't know saw blades
were in there you might try and swim and
climb over it but I don't know if
they're saw blades I don't think the the
saw blades were the reason why they died
it's what's something that's also not
really talked about very often is that
uh finding dead migrants is just a thing
that happens in other side of Texas all
the time like there's a there's a ranch
down the road in Uvalde that we go to a
lot uh that uh has had issues with that
were like there are literally dead
migrants will wash up and they just find
them
and that's that's a good uh two hours in
from the border
I feel like historically it's been the
most when when countries have had to
deal with mass mass migration like
against their will that it's been the
most gruesome defensive measures have
been taken and they just don't document
it because like otherwise or you hear
about the Roman Empire getting
overthrown by the immigration and let me
be let me be really clear this is not
like U.S defensive border policy that's
killing them it's it's just the elements
if you've ever tried to walk anywhere in
Texas with limited Provisions for days
at a time that is a very very deadly
Venture if you're not careful walk a
mile like today outside here never mind
Texas is like over 100 for the entire
time I was there yeah whatever the the
entire last week I was just back in in
San Antonio it's like 107 degrees is
kind of the normal in the middle of the
day what would be an example of U.S
defensive measures
the wall a wall is you know it's one of
those things where it's like you know
you can call the wall what you will but
a lot of Democrats said that the wall
was just a massive waste of money
it's like it's some of the lower
estimates were like single digit billion
dollars like eight billion dollars but
we can give hundreds of billions to
Ukraine yeah that's money that they need
to send to Pakistan to teach kids about
gender studies right right so it's like
that that's a that's a good you know
that's a good starting place and also
giving the the border patrol folks the
the equipment and the things that they
need to actually do their job like what
what equipment uh whether it's you know
uh just a the ability to staff the
people that they need like the people
they need to actually work the Border uh
Vehicles access to resources like and
the states are willing to do that but
the federal government isn't
oh
the federal government are they
withholding federal funds from the the
process or are they actually legally
impeding State Defense
I'm not sure if they've legally impeded
State Defense they're like doing a lot
like a lot of stuff like this I've seen
there was one example I think it was the
uh it was the the counter measure that
they put up in the water was they were
told to remove but there was another one
I think it was like in Arizona or New
Mexico that they were told to take the
big potatoes yeah yeah the shipping
container thank you yeah they blocked
off waterways with shipping containers
nope just flat ground yep and they made
a makeshift walls and shipping
containers and they're like ah you can't
do that and they're like why and they're
like we don't know but you know oh my
God yeah so it's like a state trying to
protect their own border and the federal
government actively said like you know
and it's not a tax it's not a taxpayer
money thing because they if if that were
the case they would just leave it there
but they said no you actively have to
remove this now someone said it was on
Twitter that the reason that they're
allowing the federal government's
allowing such Mass migration is
immigration is because uh the birth
rates are down and they need new slave
labor the tongue-in-cheek slavery they
need a new citizenry and like unless
we're going to have a bunch of kids
they're the writing's on the wall and
they need a larger population if they
were that philanthropic about it I think
they would openly say it
yeah like we need more people right
which is not the argument that they're
making they're not they're not that
transparent so there's there's obviously
something else at work what like a wall
what else I mean is there any how can
you prevent this this Mass illegal Mass
migration well on there well there's a
lot of a lot of things like I said like
giving excuse me giving uh like border
patrol the the tools that they need to
actually uh do their jobs a wall is a
good start but really I like a lot of
the things that I think that would help
or uh you know just the the removal of a
lot of the entitlements too
because it's like if you remove
entitlements
a lot of that desire to migrate goes
away like you've actually seen too and
it's it's a it's an actual uh observable
effect
the way that the U.S economy fluctuates
has effect on illegal immigration from
Mexico yeah which is a really
interesting stat you talk about that
that's one of the things that like
Libertarians like a lot like so there's
a lot of open borders Libertarians that
they're kind of like you know people
don't you know countries shouldn't exist
you you should just be able to move
freely where you want and stuff the only
kind of board is that there should be
your property uh borders for property
rights if you have if you have property
you can say people can come on to it but
you can States shouldn't be able to do
that and stuff
and to me it's compelling in the idea
that like people should be free right
like that's genuinely that's what my gut
instinct is but you can't have an open
border and be giving away the type of
entitlements that we do here in the U.S
you know when you've got Social Security
unemployment I all kinds of all kinds of
uh social programs that are that are
available to people that come to the uh
that that come to the US or that are
that are citizens of the U.S if you get
rid of the entitlements then you can
have open borders because the situation
is if you want to come here and work
come work even just listen to the
conversation that they're having about
in New York and where they're getting a
lot of these migrants bust in the
conversations they're having is like how
do we logistically how do we feed these
people how do we clothe these people how
do we put them into homes how do we wash
their clothes like how do we do all
these things how do we teach their
children it's like these are all just
strains on the economic system I have an
idea thrown into you don't you don't
because they're here illegally and they
shouldn't be here send them home you
gotta go back I mean you can go home you
know huge deportation you you support
that now hold on it depends on what
you're tired I I propose a program where
when people come to the Border we ask
them what country are you coming from
and we asked them a few we have a
questionnaire about their country and
our country
and they're allowed to stay
because the same time communist leftists
are lining up on the other side of the
Border
and we do a one-for-one swap with the
anti-communist Venezuelans and Cubans
for the Communist hipster brooklynites
and I think we can all agree that's a
good thing that's a that's like uh what
you think people do with like prisoners
of War they call it repopulation where
they would just take a huge section
swap it somewhere against their will
otherwise yeah Southern border and
there's a line of people and a guy walks
up it's like way from like Venezuela and
it's like okay and uh your views on
socialism it's really bad I want to go
to America it's like okay and you sir uh
you're where are you from I'm from
Brooklyn and you let communism I do swap
you go to Cuba you go to you go to
Communism land like you dreamed of so
like social security goes to illegal
immigrants at the moment I don't I
really don't know what what kind of
entitlements these people are getting at
the moment I don't think it's Social
Security but think about what you can
get without an ID yeah and there's a lot
and so uh you can you can actually get
an ID without uh proper documentation
and then once you have an ID you can
apply for literally anything
people people don't understand that uh
our system of you know welfare
it's it's not like everything's
integrated perfectly and they know
exactly who everyone is all the time
it's not like this gigantic Mainframe
has your face your social your Facebook
profile and then when you apply they're
like it all makes sense now when you go
to one agency they're like probably
that's why a lot of people who are not
citizens get driver's licenses and they
get registered to vote there was an old
lady who voted being not being a citizen
because they uh she got her license they
automatically registered registered her
she did not know she wasn't allowed to
do it or whatever it doesn't matter and
they were like that's a felony you're
going to prison you're not a citizen you
can't vote thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time